one of the great fantasies of the left
is that if the older generation simply
dies off all their policy goals will be
achieved in 2013 oprah winfrey mused
after two elections of president obama
that it might require older white
americans to die for america to achieve
racial progress she said there are still
generations of people older people who
are born and bred and marinated in that
prejudice and racism and they just have
to die now bill nye bill nye the
purported science guy is thinking along
the same track he told the LA Times on
Wednesday quote climate change deniers
by way of example are older it's
generational we're going to have to wait
out for these people to age out if they
say age out is a euphemism for die but
it'll happen I guarantee you that'll
happen that's true death does happen so
these musings are not only pathetically
immoral they are anti-democratic the
notion behind a representative Republic
is that people can be convinced on the
issues if na hasn't convinced people
that global warming is a catastrophic
threat requiring massively burdensome
government interference that would be
his fault
perhaps he's too busy producing songs
about my sex junk or cartoons with
polysexual ice cream scoops but the
fantasy of the left is that the
demographics of the country will move in
their direction if they can just get rid
of undesirable populations and that has
a pretty dark undertone hoping your
political opponents croak so that you
can win legislative battles without
having to win the argument
and its massive nastiness while
conservatives sometimes joke about
leftist having fewer babies and then
losing the argument through demographics
we're not actually rooting for that to
happen nor do we think that lack of kids
from left this would be a necessity for
political victory but on the left the
hatred for those old white Americans is
pretty real and it's one of the driving
factors behind that constituencies hard
turn toward candidates like President
Trump I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
all righty so we are going to get to
everything that is happening over at UC
Berkeley I'll give you the update on
that
I'm going to give you the update on
everything that it's a president Trump
gave an ill-advised
shall we say interview with the New York
Times we will talk about it we will also
be talking about the latest on Obamacare
but before we do any of that first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at lyft
so right now lyft is looking for drivers
and the drivers in lifts are the
happiest drivers that are I know because
I use lifts all the time every time I
never tell them that that lift is a
sponsor of the program I always just ask
them how do you like driving for less
and the answer universally is really
like it and I make a lot of money on the
side and that's what lyft is great for
because lyft offers in-app tipping when
you drive for lyft you keep 100% of the
tips drivers have been paid over 150
million dollars in tips since the
feature was introduced I assume that's
more than one driver that's one
super-rich driver Express pay actually
lets drivers pay almost instantly
instead of you waiting for weeks and
they've taken the guesswork now to pick
up save a new a MP device that uses
color coding to help passengers find
their drivers you can make hundreds of
dollars per week plus tips if you want
to make more money you drive more it is
a simple formula and happy drivers mean
happy passengers I've always thought
that lifts those great job and that's
because they keep their drivers happy
which says something about how you will
do if you drive with lips so join the
ride-sharing company that truly cares
about its drivers lift calm / capiro
today lift
ly ft.com / Imperial tonight you get a
$500 new driver bonus right off the bat
lift calm / Shapiro today that is lift
calm / Shapiro limited time only in
terms you apply lift calm / Shapiro ly
ft.com
/ Shapiro check that out become a driver
great way for people to make a side
income or main income depending on how
much you drive so go over and check it
out ok so the update on UC Berkeley so
yesterday I am sitting around minding my
own business design apt to do and I get
a notice from young America's Foundation
that UC Berkeley is now attempting to
quash my appearance on September 14 so
they have gotten back to ya and they are
now saying that they are not going to
allow me to speak there on September
14th
have the facilities this was their
excuse they always have to come up with
an excuse they can't just say he's
conservative we're not going to have him
instead what they do is they make an
excuse so according to you app in an
email to the the Berkeley College
Republicans Dean of Students Joseph
green well and student organization
coordinator Millicent Morris Cheney
denied the student's request for a venue
for September 14 2017 despite what
Morris training called extensive efforts
Berkeley has explained earlier that I
was welcome on their campus and they
were committed to supporting my right to
free speech the administrator said that
Brooklyn can only host make quote when
events are held at a time and location
that allow for the provision of any
required security measures that's pretty
open-ended they did not provide
alternative dates nor do they provide
alternative venues when UF asked for
excuses meaning like can you give us all
of the people who are speaking in the
venues that have over 500 seats that
night
Berkeley apparently didn't even provide
that so right now what it looks like is
Berkeley making an excuse for not
hosting me on September 14th and
offering no alternative date now
Berkeley says they're going to
accommodate they say that they are going
to offer alternative dates or they're
going to allow us maybe to rent a
different room but they're going to have
to do that otherwise they're going to be
hit with another lawsuit because the
fact is that the Bruin College
Republicans yeah I we all have a right
to speak on the campus they're a duly a
duly appointed student group they went
through all the usual measures there is
nothing wrong with me speaking at UC
Berkeley in fact the proof is in the
pudding I spoke there in April 2016 at
no problem we had a packed room about
300 students no protesters nothing so if
Berkeley doesn't actually get out of the
way here or provide the security
necessary to quash their identified
insane people then they would be in
violation of the First Amendment this is
one of the excuses the left is fond of
using now they don't openly say that
they won't have conservative speakers
instead what they do is they use the
hecklers veto so they say okay well if
there's going to be a bunch of violent
people who show up and make trouble then
we have to ensure safety and so we have
to cancel the event outright which gives
the veto to the worst people on earth
that gives the veto to those Antipa
thugs the what it really incentivizes is
a bunch of people on the right to do the
same thing the left-wing speaker's right
go out there and threaten violence the
left-wing speakers get canceled it's
horrible precedent it's really bad now I
thought something was really funny
there's somebody who tweeted me
yesterday and they said well now that
Berkeley's trying to quash you
to upset with yourself that you didn't
support the people who stormed the stage
and Shakespeare in the Park I said no
I'm happy I did not support those people
since they have the exact same rights
that I do I mean it's a very very easy
one if I have the right to speak in a
public place like Berkeley then they
have the right to perform at a stage
that they have the new ability to
perform it but I think these principles
have to be held consistently again I'm
hopeful that Berkeley will work it out
I'm hopeful that Berkeley will hear the
hue and cry that has arisen from the
masses and that they will back down off
of this and they will not allow
themselves to be intimidated by the
Antipa people but there are measures
available in case Berkeley does not do
what Berkeley is supposed to do and if
they want to read that as a legal threat
they certainly should because there will
be legal action if they do not do what
they are necessitated to do under the
First Amendment to the United States
Constitution also Governor Brown
Governor Jerry Brown of this used to be
great state of California I would
appreciate if you would get control of
your own campuses University of
California is under the auspices of the
California state government when the
when Berkeley was filled with riots in
the 1960s Ronald Reagan sent in the
National Guard if Jerry Brown allows
Berkeley to continue being a place where
free speech is shut down
he is just demonstrating that he is
wildly incompetent to his job and or
helping out the worst form of anti
speech fascism in America that is
happening on today's college campuses so
I'll continue to bring you updates as
all this develops I mean honestly
perfectly so stupid for doing this I'm
supposed to testify in front of Congress
next week next week about government
shutdowns of free speech on college
campuses so I guess thanks to Berkeley
for providing me material so welcome
there guys but we will bring you updates
as those arises okay in other news from
President Trump yesterday had an
interview with the New York Times and
President Trump should not do these
interviews of the New York Times it's
really funny because for all the talk
about Trump destroys the media no one
gives the media more fodder than
President Trump right he goes and he
does these interviews Maggie Haberman of
the New York Times I think Maggie
Haberman is quite a good reporter but
Trump obviously desires the love of
Maggie Haberman in the New York Times
because he does interviews with her
regularly routinely he does interviews
with with the New York Times because he
reads the New York Times because he grew
up in New York and he subscribed I'm
sure it's in the New York Times and so
he's interested in what they have to say
he dropped
bunch of bombshells in the middle of
this interview that are just not helpful
it's it's really bad that Trump is is
you know I don't know that he's a stupid
man but I will say that he is a guy who
really does not listen to what he says
he has you know if the Trump family sort
of the Bluth family in interested
development then I have
I mean he's played all of the different
blues parts at one point or another you
know he's played the right and the
Democrats think that he is George senior
right I may have committed a little
light treason that's what the Democrats
think of it you know sometimes he plays
the the Trump jr. kind of Joe Bluth part
I've made a horrible mistake right now
he's playing I think that he's actually
playing Tobias Tobias team K and the
reason that I say that is because Tobias
his whole problem throughout the entire
series that he says ridiculous things
that he can't hear himself rightly good
and then if he's confronted with tape he
still can't hear it so he'll say things
that are complete gay sexual
connotations and everyone around him
here is it but he doesn't hear it
because he's incapable of hearing so I
feel like that's what Trump does
sometimes because if you were a Democrat
and he said you know the awesome was
would be a trump said X within 48 hours
Trump will be out there saying that
thing and he won't even like understand
that he's saying it's really it's really
a mix it you know Trump says things that
are honest and some things that are true
and he says whatever comes to his mind
first and so you know that's not a good
thing today actually is a perfect day
for good Trump bathroom so we have
access to good Trump bad Trump
[Music]
all righty so we'll get to good Trump in
a little bit but we'll start with a drum
so Trump does this interview with the
New York Times and he starts off by
saying that he would never have picked
Jeff Sessions for attorney general if he
had known that sections was going to
recuse himself the reason that this is
intensely stupid is because if you want
to suggest to people that you are trying
to cover up some sort of crime with
Russia what you don't do is say I really
wish I had an attorney general who
hadn't recused himself so he could
protect me from the investigation into
Russia this would be the thing that you
wouldn't say so naturally Trump being
tobias funke just says it and doesn't
even really understand what he's saying
so here he is - Don Olsen's analyst
therapist gets the job right after he
gets the job he reduces was that a
mistake well section should have never
accused himself and if he what if he was
going to recuse himself he should have
told me before he took the job and I
want to pick somebody else zero so Jeff
Sessions takes the job gets into the job
refuses themselves I didn't have which
which frankly I think it's very unfair
to the president how do you take a job
and then reduce yourself if he would
have recused himself before the job I
would have said thanks Jeff but I can't
you know another thing it's extremely
unfair and that's a mile board to the
president so he refuses okay so clearly
Trump is very upset about him refusing
himself over to the Russia thing so to
be fair to Trump the fact is the Barack
Obama used Eric Holder as his shield and
sword the entirety of his administration
he called Barack Holder called Barack
Obama his wing man they said they're
like best buddies these two hang out and
obviously anytime Holder needed to
protect be protected when he was in
contempt of Congress Obama stepped in
asserted executive privilege to protect
him so it's not unwarranted the Trump
thinks the AG is supposed to be sort of
his protector but it's not good right
you're now suggesting that he that
there's something that is really
terrible that's going to happen because
AG sessions recused himself on Russia
and by the way AG sessions a very active
Attorney General is there really
ratcheted up prosecutions on
immigration he's done some things that
are not so good either like yesterday he
came out and he really ratcheted up the
idea of asset forfeiture asset
forfeiture is this unconstitutional
notion that if you arrest somebody and
you don't even charge them then you can
just seize their property which is
really quite awful but his sessions a
very active AG his job is not entirely
the Russian investigation if Trump is
saying that the sole qualifiers here was
going to be that the AG was not able to
investigate the Russia thing and that he
would have left sessions at McCole if
you had known that what it's going to
suggest to people is that you wish that
sessions were there to protect you right
now I don't know if that's what Trump
wishes but that's certainly the
connotation of what he is suggesting
okay then he goes further with this he
says you know I really would prefer if
Robert Muller who is the special
prosecutor he shouldn't look into my
family's finances okay this is again
remember Robert Muller was only
appointed not because AG sessions
recused himself but sessions recused
himself and then Trump fired Comey
in order to fire Comey if you remember
the former FBI director in order to fire
economy he requested a letter from rod
Rosenstein who is the Deputy Attorney
General Sessions couldn't write the
letter supposedly because he was recused
on the Russia stuff
she had rod Rosenstein write the letter
now rod Rosenstein is involved in the
firing of coaming and so now when Comey
comes back at Trump and he says you
fired me is basically part of a cover-up
on the Russia stuff now Rosenstein has
to recuse himself and that's how you get
the special prosecutor Robert Muller who
Rosenstein appointed Trump is now angry
at Rosenstein because he says Rosenstein
is a Democrat he's angry at sessions and
he's very angry at Muller because he
thinks special prosecutor is going to
exceed his mandate which by the way he's
not wrong about Muller is going to
exceed his mandate I'll discuss that in
a second but what Trump says here is so
not smart it's just not smart again it's
Tobias fume k it's somebody saying
something that he doesn't hear and not
good always looking at your finances
your family's fine
unrelated to Russia is that a red line
but that'd be a breach of what is actual
I was hurrying yeah I would say is by
the way I would say I don't I don't I
mean it's possible to condo or something
so you know sell a lot of kind of units
and somebody somebody from Russia by
Spandau knows I don't make money from
Russia in fact I put out a letter saying
that I don't know from one of the most
highly respected law firms accounting
firms I don't have buildings in Russia
they said I owned buildings and in
Russia I don't
they said I made money from Russia it's
not my thing I don't I don't do that
over the years I've looked at maybe
doing the deal in Russia but a net he
did okay so he continued by saying that
it was it was a violation of redline and
then he said at the very end he said
they said would you fire Muller if he
crosses that red line he said I can't I
can't answer that question because I
don't think that it's going to happen
okay so first of all here's the thing
you shouldn't say you can investigate
everything but whatever you do don't
look in that safe right this is not the
way that you're supposed to if you want
to avoid an investigation and this is
unless you're Lex Luthor and you
actually hit the Kryptonite inside the
lead in Koston coat in encased box and
you're actually trying to get Superman
to open the box you don't actually want
to say this right this is like the
police the police come in your apartment
they say can we search your apartments
they absolutely can search my apartment
just don't search under the floorboards
in my closet like what do you think is
the first place that are going to search
obviously what do you think is the very
first place they're going to search this
is the place they're going to search
obviously so it's really not
particularly smart for Trump to say
don't look at my sign-out yeah look
everywhere but whatever you do don't
look at the finances just don't do it
I'd be mad if you do it again where do
you think Muller is going to look now
and naturally this morning there's a
report out if Bob Muller where is he
looking oh yes at Trump's finances quote
do you have special counsel
investigating possible ties between
Donald Trump campaign in Russia in last
year's election is examining a broad
range of transactions involving Trump's
business as well as those of his
associates according to a person
familiar with the probe FBI
investigators and others are looking at
Russian purchases of apartments and
Trump buildings Trump's involvement in a
Contra
personal SOHO development with Russian
associates the 2013 Miss Universe
pageant in Moscow and Trump sale of a
Florida mansion to a Russian oligarch in
2008 the person said so I want to
discuss what Trump is right about here
and what he's wrong about cuz he's not
entirely wrong I think that this is
going to end with Trump firing Muller I
think this is going to get to the point
where Trump gets so annoyed that he just
fires Muller and it will be really
fascinating to see what happens next
but I think that it will be but I don't
mean that he's entirely wrong be
suspicious of what Molitor is doing I'll
explain that in just a second but before
I do that I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at my Patriot supply so
the fact is that in any situation
natural disaster or terrorist attack
economic collapse any bad situation
people tend to panic and when people
panic they go to the grocery store they
buy off the shelves and there's no food
and there's disaster preparedness in
other words it's something that you and
your family deserve here in California
earthquakes they recommend that you're
supposed to have food on hand water on
hand your flashlights your ray-ray all
these things are supposed to have most
people don't have them this is true
across the country you should certainly
be prepared in case there's some sort of
disaster that necessitates
you have some emergency food storage so
right now if you go over my friends and
my Patriots apply and get their new
survival food supply for just $99 it
includes a hundred and two servings of
breakfast lunch lunches and dinner for
less than a dollar per serving
order now 888 803 1413 888 803 1413 or
online and prepare with been calm again
it's 99 bucks for one hundred and two
servings so it's a great price prepare
with Ben calm you by sticking your quasi
forget about it until you need it but
then you're the only one who's prepared
prepare with Ben calm and that way you
know that if there's something bad that
happens you're always going to be
confident you can handle at 888 803 1413
or prepare with Ben comm 102 servings I
mean that means that you're going to be
able to feed your family for weeks so
that's that's a fantastic deal again
it's something that every family should
have and people at the office here of
Trident they say that it tastes like
home cooking so it's actually good it
doesn't taste like garbage tastes really
good apparently so go over to prepare
with Ben comm 888 803 14:13 and get your
emergency food supply just in case
something bad should happen 99 bucks is
not a is not a high price for peace of
mind okay so here is where Trump is
right about
robert muller and the entire left is
suggesting how dare trump how dare he
even suggest all these things ok so
annie mccarthy has a really good piece
today over at the journal of american
greatness which is basically the trump
defense journal but Annie McCarthy is an
honest thinker so this is not just a
knee-jerk Trump defense piece and he
says that the problem with the special
counsel he's been saying this all along
is that the investigation that Muller is
now engaging in is too broad ranging to
actually pick up on the original mandate
you remember the original mandate was to
investigate whether the Trump campaign
colluded with the Russians in cyber
hacking the DNC and then releasing
emails that was the original mandate it
is now expanded to include trumps
finances Trump's associates you could
see a case certainly where Muller
investigates and he goes into Trump's
finances and you find something totally
unrelated to Russia that's criminal or a
problem and that ends up being the
scandal that takes down Trump once you
have a special counsel these sorts of
things happen is exactly what happened
with Kenneth Starr remember Monica
Lewinsky never claimed sexual harassment
Monica Lewinsky never claimed sexual
assault Monica Lewinsky was a consensual
affair but that was uncovered by Kenneth
Starr in the process of investigating
the Paula Jones allegations and that in
turn necessitated that Bill Clinton when
he committed perjury was going to be
impeached so this is the problem with
special counsels and this is something
that Andy McCarthy points out he
suggests that in criminal law our sites
are trained on conspiracy which makes
things easy a conspiracies and agreement
to commit a violation of law to speak in
terms of collusion rather than
conspiracy only confuses matters
contrary to what you may have heard from
strategists and analysts collusion is
not a crime nor a term that has a
legally consequential meaning so that's
where we are with respect to the Trump
Tower meeting but if there's an ordinary
federal criminal case which is what
Mulder would theoretically be
investigating if there's no felony
there's no cause to investigate but
still we're investigating why because
once you get into a Special Counsel
investigation it broadens and broadens
now I was in favor of appointing the
special counsel originally simply
because I felt the Trump had no choice
at a certain point because so many
people in his administration had been
dirty by the Russia allegations sessions
and then Rosenstein in the firing of
Comey and it felt like his
administration was losing enough faith
that at certain point of special counsel
was going to be appointed whether he
liked it or not that's what's happened
but now Trump is legitimately scared
that something will be dug up on any
grounds and if I were him I'd be scared
too even if I were completely open and
honest about the rush of stuff because
once people start digging they did until
they hit bedrock they're going to dig
until they find something anything at
all and and so that is probably why
Trump is so is so upset about the
Special Counsel stuff and probably why
in the end he didn't end up firing the
Special Counsel which could precipitate
it's not a constitutional crisis his
authority to do it but it could
precipitate a major political scandal
whereby Trump didn't even do anything
and ends up in the crosshairs of the
Democrats for impeachment through not
really doing anything well want to
explain more about this plus Trump does
something on Russia again I'm going to
I'm going to say that this is more to
buy a student aid than malevolence but
we're going to we're going to talk about
that in just a second for that going to
have to go over to Daily wire calm for
$9.99 a month you can subscribe to daily
wire we're not just an audio show we are
a video show for people who listen and
you can watch the entire video show over
at Daily wire comm for $9.99 a month
that means that you also get to be part
of the mailbag which we'll be doing
tomorrow yet to watch Andrew Clavin show
live all the way through plus you get
his mailbag which is doing today you're
going to be able to watch the the many
times mentioned but never yet seen
Michael Noel's show god help us that
will be coming out I think the week
after next and so you'll be able to
watch that live which is very exciting
for some and you're going to want to
check that out so go over to daily
wire.com and check that out it'll really
be fun I think they know most shows
could be really funny so you're going to
want to check that out and if you get an
annual subscription then not only do you
get all of the things mentioned above
and you get the website ad free which
you get for any subscriptions but you
also get for $99 a year
this magnificent incomparable
inconceivably great tumbler it says upon
it leftist tears hot or cold it is
etched in silver purest silver it
probably is not actually silver it's
probably aluminum but in any case it
looks beautiful it is dishwasher safe
you will enjoy you will love it you'll
treasure it forever you'll pass it down
to your children one day on planet of
the HD alone cover it in a cave next to
a crying baby doll because it is so
great this left this tears tumble or hot
or cold
check it out with the annual
subscription or gonna listen later go to
iTunes or SoundCloud subscribe leave us
a review whatever number of stars you
were going to give us add five and then
leave it we always appreciate your
listenership
the
is the largest conservative podcast in
the United States
[Music]
okay so the Trump again I think he says
things without thinking about them that
can be read in two ways one is that's
completely innocent
tobias fume k is not in fact an anal
rapist he's an analyst therapist right
and then there it could be read in like
the most awful a possible way so Trump
last night he's asked about this second
Putin meeting so the media's been making
a big deal out of the fact that at this
big dinner there was this big dinner
with all of the g20 leaders and their
spouses and from halfway through the
dinner his wife is sitting apparently
next to Melania is sitting next to Putin
he is sitting next to the first lady of
Japan and he gets bored and he walks
over and he sits down next to Melania
and Putin and proceeds to engage with
them he said it was a brief meeting
everybody there says it was like an hour
and nobody from the US government was
there so we don't know what was said we
only know what Trump says was that I
think by the way the funniest thing
about this this is Italy funny is that
apparently the first lady of Japan when
sitting next to trump in his interview
with the New York Times you said yeah I
was sitting there next to her and she
didn't really speak English people
didn't speak it turns out she's fluent
in English so she was legitimately
apparently pretending not to speak
English and she would not have to talk
to Trump which is it that's money again
sorry as it's really funny because he
sits down next to Melania Putin and
people are saying what are you talking
about for an hour and Trump uses
legitimately the worst excuse available
he says I talked about Russian adoption
with Vladimir Putin that's what we
talked about for an hour or dessert I
went that just to say hello to Melania
and while I was near said a little food
really pleasantries more than anything
else was that a long conversation but
it's no could be 15 minutes just talk
about things
we actually is very interesting we
talked about production he did Russian
touch yeah I always found that
interesting because you know he ended
that years ago and I actually talked
about Russian adoption with them which
is interesting because that was a part
of the conversation that Don had with us
meaning that I think as I said most
people you know when they call they say
by the way we have information on your
opponent I think most politicians just
with a lot of people they said you
taking a meeting like common well no no
you don't do that okay so here's why you
don't do that Donald Trump's original
excuse about the meeting with the
Russians that it was about Russian
adoption and turned out that was bull
now Trump is being asked what was your
meeting about he uses the exact same
excuse his son used that turned out to
be bull can't you make up anything else
say the weather our kids jiu-jitsu
riding horses bareback fighting bears
bathing an antler blood which apparently
Putin does do any of those things right
you can do any of those things but
instead you go directly to the excuse
that your son used that turned out to be
false within 48 hours why why God
waffling president Trump please for the
love of God please just no just there
are things called teleprompters okay I
understand you don't like using them but
you're so much better when you use the
teleprompter
he's given some great speeches on
teleprompter he spoke in front of a
joint session of Congress terrific on
teleprompter he spoke in Saudi Arabia
not my favorite speech not a bad speech
on teleprompter right spoke in Poland
terrific speech on teleprompter he does
not have a teleprompter for these
interviews his lawyers must just be
thinking oh god oh god he's going to
talk to the New York Times again no no
no don't do it please don't do it okay
and then Trump follows this up by saying
Jim Comey tried to blackmail me okay so
he his suggestion is that Jim Comey
basically was trying to was trying to
coerce him into doing something but
isn't it clear what it is that Comey
wanted to hear his Trump he also had
some really fascinating choice word for
a former FBI director Comey he sure did
and as we know he has said any number of
choice words James Comey for some time
but he was very specific that he you
know believed that Comey was trying to
essentially get leverage over him with
that dossier making all sorts of wild
allegations about President Trump and
his appearance in Russia in 2013 you
know he as we know he was not happy with
Comey for quite some time
long before he actually fired him there
had been some belief that he might even
fire him immediately upon taking office
he believes Comey did that in order to
get leverage over him to keep his job
essentially the company wanted to keep
his job and that that was the point in
showing it to him you know again the the
president feels sort of indicated as I
think you have seen him say publicly
that Comey had to acknowledge under oath
that he had told the president three
times that he was under investigation he
said he would not say that publicly
because it might change the president
just doesn't accept that as an answer no
soon Comey is political actor no
question but when he says that Comey was
trying to blackmail him with the dossier
we have to go back in history originally
what Comey said is I presented this
dossier you remember BuzzFeed released
the dossier which is full of false
information about Russian P tapes and
stuff about trumping P down by processes
and all that sort of nonsense and Comey
said I presented that to the president
because it was going around Capitol Hill
I wanted him to be aware of it I wanted
him to be aware that it was being
investigated and that we had no proof
that any of it was true and now Trump is
saying that that was supposed to be
leverage like that was going to be
released by Comey he doesn't have any
proof of that and what it more looks
like is again that he's in some sort of
poop fight with Comey
than that he's actually rightfully
trying to defend himself there's two
things that are happening here Trump can
be completely innocent in all of this
but he has to stop saying things that
make him sound guilty and make him sound
like he is he is getting involved in
things he shouldn't be involved in so
okay this is all under the heading bad
Trump it is not useful it is harmful you
should not speak off the cuff like this
it is really not worthwhile okay now
it's time for some good Trump at long
last it's time for some good Trump so I
criticize president Trump yesterday and
the day before and I have for weeks that
he has been completely hands-off on this
health care thing he's been very
hands-off on health care policy and it
makes sense fitting hands-off on the
health care policy because the truth is
he doesn't know what he's talking about
when it comes to health insurance policy
if you asked him what's in the health
insurance bill there is no one in
America who thinks the Donald Trump is
an expert on what is in Trump care part
1 part 2 part 3 what's in Obamacare what
all these things do in fact there's a
poll out today that shows that nearly
two-thirds of Americans 62% now think
that the federal government's job is to
ensure that all Americans have health
care coverage if they all agree with
Bernie Sanders
two percent that would include President
Trump back in January said quote we're
going to have insurance for everybody
there was a philosophy in some circles
that if you can't pay for it you don't
get it that's not going to happen with
us I mean that's what Trump actually
said so he buys into that as well and
that confusion as I have said has led to
the inability of a lot of Republicans to
come to a conclusion on what exactly
Trump even wants them to do and so
that's been a problem Trump is now
attempting a little too late he's trying
to apply leverage to some of the
senators to vote for something I am glad
that he is attempting to apply leverage
the big problem is that if you apply
leverage without knowing what you're
trying to leverage people into it makes
it sort of difficult so here is what
Trump is doing that is right he's trying
to apply leverage yesterday he had a
bunch of senators to the White House and
he started getting rough with them on
camera and here's what it looked like we
can repeal but we should repeal and
replace and we shouldn't leave town
until this is complete until this bill
is on my desk and until we all go over
to the Oval Office I'll sign it and we
can celebrate for the American people
thank you very much thank you thank you
okay so he then continued along these
lines by openly threatening senator
Heller senator Dean Heller from the
state of Nevada is a moderate he does
not believe in full repeal basically or
at least he's made noises along those
lines and from actively warned Heller if
you don't do what I want then you might
not be a senator for very long I think I
have to get him back that's right I
color City Nick what I want to stay you
didn't go out there this was the one we
were worried about you are there but
you're going to be you're going to do it
look he wants to remain a senator
doesn't he okay
and I think the people of your state
which I know very well I think they're
going to appreciate what you hopefully
will do it looks like I just want to
crawl in a hole and die but here's
here's okay so it's good that Trump's
applying pressure well it'd be better is
a trump applying pressure toward a
particular actual standard so the
problem is this let's say that you are a
congress person your senator and you're
presented with a bill and the bill
contains some good stuff and it contains
some bad stuff what do you do do you
vote for it or do you vote against it
now Trump might like the bill but he
also might not so you might say okay you
vote for it because Trump is going to
use his leverage as I have been
suggesting he should do he's going to
use his leverage to harm me if I don't
do what he wants right that would be the
idea except that a bunch of Republicans
voted in the house in favor of Trump
care part-1 and Trump had a big
celebratory meeting at the White House
and then three days later he came out
and said that the bill was mene mene
mene why would you put yourself on the
line with your own constituents to vote
for an unpopular bill that has 20
percent approval rating under the
auspices the president's going to
pressure you if you know that he's going
to stab you in the back a minute
everything goes out so the president in
order for threat to work if I threatened
if I were to threaten mathis virus a
Malthus if you do something if you do X
I'm going to fire you I have to define
what X is right so that Malthus knows
not to do it if I were to save Malthus
you have to make me look good on the
show or I'm going to fire you
then it's Amathus his job to make me
look good on the show there's only so
much he can do but he does the best that
he can if I were to say to if I were to
say to Malthus however Malthus do some
stuff but I'm going to fire you some
stuff and it's going to get done or you
may not have a job tomorrow Malthus may
not sleep particularly well but Malthus
is not going to know what the hell to do
right does he is he supposed to use the
camera in a particular way he's supposed
to cut to a particular question she's
supposed to make sure that all the clips
are cut to their specified length what
is he supposed to do
he doesn't know in order for a threat to
work you have to have a natural a
natural action and then a consequence to
that action right if you do X I will do
Y what's the X here some sense repeal in
our place that's super vague because
they're not going to pass a pure repeal
it appears it appears that they don't
the votes for this Lamar Alexander the
senator from Tennessee he says we don't
have 40 votes to just repeal Obamacare
I'll explain why this is the case in a
second but here with Lamar Alexander
from Tennessee saying exactly this
better than the time but it's obvious to
me number one with the president papers
their deal in the place of course we
can't repeal at all we're repealing
parts of the Affordable Care Act and
replacing it with parts we think will
improve it and
I said that sucks that's the main thing
III favors you want to forget to you any
favor that I favor that you I don't
think there forty votes to repeal and
say to the American people well trust us
to come up with something in the next
couple of years I don't think that's a
very very clearly what do you think the
Republicans are not going to just repeal
so the plan from McConnell was we're
going to repeal Obamacare and then we'll
figure out something to do is that the
problem is twofold one the actual repeal
bill from 2015 doesn't repeal all of
Obamacare even plain repeal I think they
should vote on it because I think that
they need pressure put on them to
actually come up with a full repeal but
the what the actual repeal bill did in
remember they can only do what's called
reconciliations and backtrack
reconciliation process means that you
need 51 votes in order to pass something
reconciliation means that you can only
pass a law that has an impact on the
budget that's just these arcane Senate
rules okay if you don't need 60 votes to
invoke cloture you only need 51 in order
to pass a bill the bill has to impact
the budget the problem is the regular
bamaca regulations don't actually impact
the budget directly so it's kind of hard
to use reconciliation in order to get
rid of all of Obamacare you end up
keeping a lot of the regulations but
getting rid of the subsidies and the
taxes that inevitably will kill the
Obamacare exchanges but these insurance
companies are still required to cover
pre-existing conditions which is going
to drive premiums up that's what
Republicans are afraid of that's why a
lot of them don't want to vote for pure
repeal the case in favor of voting for
pure repeal like this is that once you
do that then you're going to be forced
into a position where either you pass a
bunch of regulatory reform and do away
with a lot of these regulations or all
the prices go up it applies a certain
amount of pressure but it's a gamble
it's a gamble and a lot of people don't
want to take that gamble because the
premiums go up and people are tossed off
of Medicaid then the number of uninsured
go up and people who are still trying to
get insurance might be in a fair bit of
trouble so that's why there's a case
against plain repeal in the 2015 census
that could actually try to repeal
Obamacare wholesale and then try to
leverage the Senate Rules Committee the
Senate rules there's actually a person
who's like the rules expert who rules on
this stuff try to pressure her to
actually allow that to go through that
would be the best available move but the
Republicans are now stuck between a bit
of a rock and a hard
but when they say repeal and replace
that's not clear what they mean it's
like when people say immigration reform
it's a buzzword it doesn't mean anything
is immigration reform strengthening our
immigration system or is it weakening
our immigration system what does it mean
to repeal and replace does it mean we're
going to get rid of Obamacare or does it
mean we're going to replace Obamacare
with Obamacare part two and so this is
why Trump even Trump is unclear on this
the Republican caucus is unclear on this
nobody knows what they want to do so
when Trump tries to apply pressure to a
caucus that doesn't know what it wants
to do and he doesn't know what he wants
to do you end up with this sort of wild
confusion and you do end up with a fair
bit of posturing so Mitch McConnell
knowing that he's not going to be able
to pass a plan repeal he said yesterday
we're going to vote to wipe the slate
clean of Obama care we will have a vote
on this even if it doesn't pass as I
announced last evening after consulting
with both the White House and our
members we've decided to hold the vote
to open debate on Obamacare repeal to
early next week the Obamacare repeal
legislation will ensure a stable
two-year transition period which will
allow us to wipe the slate clean and
start over with real patient center
health care reform okay so we will see
if that actually happens is that vote
actually takes place if it does then
it's at least in part an attempt by
Mitch McConnell to simply get the
Republican caucus off his back saying
okay we tried to pass it and then we
weren't actually able to pass it so that
is what it is
again this is because the Republican
Party does not agree on what to do it
doesn't agree on the means that it has
available to do it and it can't even
make the argument again this entire
thing could have been avoided in two
ways one if you're going to leave
Obamacare in place you should have
called the Democrats in from day one and
said we want to fix all of this won't
you help us and then the Democrats would
say no need see we want to fix it they
wouldn't help us right that was the
first way to do this the second way to
do this was to say we want to repeal the
entire thing wholesale and we are going
to work continuously to do that and then
say okay we don't have the votes to do
it give us more votes repet to do this
sort of repeal and replace routine where
it's all bollixed up and you don't know
what your goals are you'll end up in a
bad position and instead what you're
going to end up with is democrats
claiming that you are the scourge of the
world which is what democrats like Cory
Booker are doing the senator from New
Jersey says it's all sinister and evil
it's just terrible terrible terrible I
mean that's not just
cynical it's actually sinister here is a
guy that promised can
consistently that he was hey only I can
fix this that I'm taking on the guy that
I'm going to make health care for
everybody I'm going to get affordable oh
it's going to be I think the word he
used was terrific
well he completely abdicated that
responsibility that completely broken
that promise he outsource this health
care process to people like Mitch
McConnell and Paul Ryan and didn't even
try to reach out to one Democrat in the
Senate no call didn't call one Democrat
didn't call us up to the White House to
try to work with us a great deal maker
failed to make a deal yeah and so now
he's just saying that I'm going to
imperil 30 million Americans if
Obamacare fails it's not just people
going to say hey policy doesn't just
fail that means Americans will get hurt
badly
and you'll see very devastating things
happen so that's not just a cynical way
that's violating his promises that
sinister it is in and it's evil Tuukka
plot against Americans like that okay so
this is a case that Democrats are going
to make and Republican incompetent it's
gonna be a little bit of a hard case but
we will see you know how it works Daniel
Horowitz has a piece today in which he
talks about how to defang Obamacare even
without full repeal and it's it's pretty
good you should check it out over a
conservative review he talked about
cost-sharing associations and and and
forcing people to post their prices on
particular on particular cost so we can
actually have some open competition all
these are good idea there are lots of
good ideas that can be brought to bear
but Republicans have to decide what they
want to do and Trump has to decide what
he wants to push okay time for some
things I like things I ate and then
we'll do the big idea so so before we do
that actually I first want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at Beachbody on
demand so have you ever looked at this
right here and thought how did that
become so magnificent I of course I'm
pointing to my own magnificent physic
well one of the ways it became so
magnificent is by using Beachbody on
demand of course there are people who
are much better examples and you can see
all of them working out at Beachbody on
demand you can try out all of their
courses it's all of the courses that
you've heard of are its p90x and
insanity and 21 day fix and when you go
to Beachbody on demand then you can get
all of these courses with a free trial
membership right now so whenever I
travel I use Beachbody on
man because I try to work out every
single day which is of course why I'm
such a beautiful hunk of humanity but
when you're on the road it is great when
you are at home it is great you don't
need any equipment they give you a wide
variety of workouts so you never get
bored it's always been my problem is
that when I work out I get bored it's
why I can't get on the treadmill to run
for 8 miles I need a new workout all the
time and that's why Beachbody on demand
is so fantastic because they have
legitimately hundreds of different
options for you to use and it's just
great so top so Beachbody Ahn's man
gives you the ability to stream these
hundreds of workouts again I've used
p90x before it's fantastic it's become
world-famous of course they also have
recipe videos showing you what you are
what you can eat how to cook kid or
vegan even vegan friendly meals if
that's your if that's your game and you
can practice your bartending skills even
so they have all of these courses
available to you at Beachbody on demand
all you have to do is text Shapiro to
thirty thirty thirty so you go to your
phone type in 30 30 30 and then text
Shapiro and get full access to the
entire platform for free right now and
it gives you step-by-step program guides
workout calendars hundreds of courses
recipes workbooks I mean just fantastic
all the way through Shapiro 30 30 30
texted to 30 30 30 you get that free
trial membership and you have access to
all of these things whether you need to
lose weight or whether you just want to
tone whether you're big fatso and you
just want to make sure that you don't
die in next year then texting Shapiro to
30 30 30 is the way to do it get
Beachbody on demand and check it out and
that also lets them know that we sent
you okay time for some things I like
some things I hate and then the big idea
so things I like so John McCain was
diagnosed really tragically with brain
cancer and a lot of scummy disgusting
human beings are today tweeting out
things like they're happy that he got
brain cancer because they disagree with
him politically okay first of all let it
be said John McCain is not a terrorist
supporter John McCain is not an evil
person he's not somebody that you would
shoot he's not somebody that it would be
appropriate it was a douchey he's not
evil man and you're not at war with him
so stop with the crap about how you want
John McCain to die okay what you would
really prefer is for John McCain not to
be elected right you'd prefer for John
McCain not to be elected but that does
not mean that you should be wishing
death on a guy you disagree with and I
disagree with John McCain on a lot of
things a lot of things I thought
campaign finance reform was terrible I
think the Thomas foreign policy is not
great
but the the scummy people who are
suggesting that John McCain ought to die
just scum of the earth so today in honor
of John McCain things I like faith of my
father's is John McCain's autobiography
and memoir all about his family and his
time in Vietnam it's actually a really
good book with with Mark Salter and it's
shockingly good
it's a shockingly good memoir which is
which is me he wrote this back in I
think 2000 so it's not from his
presidential run in 2008 and he tells it
really really well all the way through
and from from his grandfather to his
father to himself his being shot down
over North Vietnam spending years in
POWs counselor he was beaten nearly
death tortured nearly allowed to die
they offered him the out to come home
because he was an admiral son if he
would just help them with a propaganda
he said no and it ends actually with
McCain being released by the EDS appeal
W it doesn't have anything after that so
it's really more about his military
career in his family's military career
it's actually a really good book faith
of my fathers John McCain an honorable
man okay for all of the talk about his
politics an honorable man who did
amazing service for the United States it
was you know he deserves our respect and
our prayers okay
speaking of POWs there's a movie if you
don't want to watch the if you don't
want to read the book there there's a
they did make a movie version on A&E I
think but I've never actually seen it so
I can't recommend it but you want to
watch a great movie about what it was
like to be a Vietnam piw like an actual
Vietnam POWs were a hertog made a very
good film called rescue dawn with
Christian Bale one of Christian Bale's
Western own parts didn't do great
business at the box office but is a very
hard-nosed good film about what exactly
happened and about an escape from
Vietnam POWs camp came out in 2006
member seeing in theatres and being
pretty struck by it here's a little bit
the trailer tomorrow morning zero 500
hours we have to cross over into Laos
now this is white with Chinese danglers
first mission
this is classified no one can know
Oh
why are you in this war against I never
wanted to go to war I wanted to fly
- I love America America gave me wings I
will not sign it absolutely not
[Music]
here longer than people know two and a
half year ago now two and a half years
ago keep your head down your mouth shut
your best chance of surviving you can
run in here if you like but I'm gonna
scram make that a camp without water
doors five point in two days out there
kachunk oldest to prison and they took
quite a good film it's a little over
long but it's really well shot and it's
really well acted and and it's it's
based on a true story I mean this is not
a false story this is a true story and
the other people in the a me can see
from the traveling people were there for
four years on end there was a lot of
talk about whether POWs were still there
after the end of the Vietnam War and and
whether they were left there to dive and
it's really a tragic story okay so time
for some things that I hate okay so the
as you know I'm a big Game of Thrones
fan I think Game of Thrones is the best
show on TV I don't think that it's
particularly close and the only other
competitor is probably man in the high
castle which is really terrific from
Amazon but David Benioff and DB Weiss
we're the showrunners they have a new
plan for a new series they want a helm
for HBO it's an alternative history
series titled Confederacy which it takes
place in modern-day America
with the south is separate from the
north so it's basically man in the high
castle alternative history where America
is divided not by the Germans and the
Japanese by the north and the south
which is an interesting premise except
for it's going to be really really
annoying I'll bet it's pretty troubled
and it can be very very annoying to read
all the hot takes from the left about
how the south in this show is really
like the south of today how all the
whites other
of today a really Neil Confederates who
wants his enslaved black folks okay
polls show I've talked about this on the
show before polls show that white folks
across the country have a basically
about the same level of racism
regardless of party regardless of
location there's no evidence to suggest
that southerners are more hostile to
black folks than northerners are at this
point in time the history has moved
beyond this and so I'm already
preemptively hitting the hot takes less
than the show itself I'm more
preemptively hitting the hot takes
themselves because that's going to be
really irritating they're going to do
exactly what they did with The
Handmaid's Tale they're going to suggest
that this is really about modern-day
America it's not really about what would
have happened it's about us we are
secretly just like these people I mean
is a compelling question what would have
happened if the South had won the Civil
War and it is my belief that within 20
to 25 years the South would have moved
beyond slavery anyway because that's the
direction the entire Western world was
moving and by the 1880s slavery was
outlawed in the vast majority of the
Western world would have moves probably
a South African apartheid system more
than likely which is basically they had
anyway under Jim Crow but you know thank
God for the Civil War in the freeing of
the slaves the great tragedy in the
aftermath of the Civil War was not the
Civil War itself it was that in 1876 the
Federals pulled out and allowed the
south to reimpose all these Jim Crow
sanctions on black folks that that's a
real tragedy that is yet to be told
historically well that would be
fascinating things about the loss of the
Civil War after the winning of the Civil
War in a particular way but I'm already
just warning you about the hot cakes
that are sure to come and that will be
super annoying when you have a bunch of
leftists who living who live in Beverly
Hills and see a black person only if
they cast a black person talking about
how everybody down south is racist by
the way the south is actually
significantly more integrated than
cities like Boston in the north okay one
more thing I hate it we'll have to get
big idea today because we just ran out
of time but one more thing that I hate
so as you know I am NOT a big fan of
history I do not like citizen C I'm not
a fan of it Chris Kobach is the the
Secretary of he's a Kansas secretary of
state and he works closely with the
White House and he was asked about he's
leading up Trump's voter fraud panel and
here is what he had to say he was asked
did Trump actually lose the popular vote
and here was his
Neela's answer easily celery Clinton won
the popular vote by three to five
million votes you know we may never know
the answer that we will probably never
know the answer to that question because
even if you could prove that a certain
number of votes were cast by ineligible
voters for example that's why you
wouldn't know is that 1:11 exists
because the President believes that you
would have won the popular vote I'm glad
you asked that question because actually
that's that is not the reason the
Commission exists it's not to justify to
validate or invalidate what the
president said in December or damaged
the Commission doesn't exist to evaluate
or invalidate what the president says
why don't you just say what everybody
knows is true Trump lost the popular
vote who cares
he's the president stop it okay if
you're going to do this routine where
you don't know who voted for what then
maybe Trump lost right if you were going
to say that there was voter fraud you
don't know who voted for what
Trump's margin of victory in the three
states that he won Wisconsin Michigan
and Pennsylvania right his margin of
victory there was a hundred thousand
votes it's a lot easier to make the
claim that voter fraud is 100 thousand
votes and that's one three million votes
but again if all in favor of voter fraud
Commission that looks into registration
of people who are dead and people who
are registered in more than one state I
think that is a worthwhile thing to do
what I do not think is a worthwhile
thing to do is to place that on the
tentative grounds and when I hit enter I
mean baseless grounds the Trump actually
won the popular vote that's just silly
and there's no reason to do it okay
we'll reactor tomorrow tomorrow we will
have the mailbag and we will do that it
should be awesome Mughal fulfill all of
your life longings at that time i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]